[Music]
i just wanted to hug him
[Music]
binyan broke down in tears and was
extremely anxious wait wait
as he said goodbye to auri and avi who
are headed back to the states for avi's
surgery this moment was a huge trigger
for binyam the pain he feels about
losing his first son
was on full display no lolita
i like you to musk just
at least
we're going to talk about it plus
i never had a chance to say i'm sorry
corey met up with his former we're just
going to call it what it is mistress
jenny for closure and he told evelyn
about the full extent of their
relationship she was
my girlfriend
i'm gonna throw up as expected evelyn
unleashed her wrath now corey is laying
in the bed that he made
or should i say hammock because evelyn
kicked him out
and she said she wants a divorce i want
him to suffer
i hope it's so cold outside there's a
million mosquitoes to buy him
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia i am
back from a birthday vacate but even
though i was relaxing i still have my
eye on everything that's going down with
ari and benyam
it's a lot these two have some eventful
lives that's for sure so watching it is
my surgical intervention which means as
soon as possible last episode we learned
that baby avi has a hernia and he needs
surgery but without bingham's approval
ari made the decision to take avi back
to the states for the procedure like i
have my ticket to go
oh my god he doesn't tell me are you
right kids yes i bought it they bought
the ticket baby now
well i do think she should have allowed
binyam to be part of that decision
because
it's his son too
i can also see her logic she understands
firsthand binium's fear of losing his
family and at times fear can get in the
way of you making sound decisions you
can't not trust the whole world because
something happened between the two of
you after chatting with ari's mom who's
an er nurse hang in there benjamin it's
okay benniam felt a little better about
ari taking ivy to the u.s
but deuce has ex-wife leaving ethiopia
with his first son for a trip to the u.s
and never coming back the anxiety was
hard to shake he looks so cute
don't go
you know you don't want me to go but
i don't want to go
i have to go
tonight i leave to go back to the u.s so
that avi can get the hernia surgery that
he needs
and even though i'll only be gone one
month vinnie is still struggling to
trust me that i am coming back
when she says struggling she means that
the day before she and avi were set to
leave
benyam got mad
and hit her passport i was very
upset and felt like that was like an
aggressive
act towards me
but i do understand that he's not acting
like himself because he's so traumatized
by what happened with his ex-wife well
thank goodness she's so understanding
and gentle
i want to tell you something
she attempted to give him some peace by
buying him a gift which he was extremely
giddy about he turned into a little kid
anton scaramucci
oh look at him
ari went on to pull out a ring which
says forever family on it and she put it
on his ring finger now you can't figure
this out ever again okay i'm gonna take
care of yourself she was trying to knock
out two birds with one stone here yes
i'm sure she wanted to let him know that
she loves him and she will come back but
i think she also wanted to mark her
territory while she's gone hopefully he
actually keeps the ring on though and if
we really want to get real the ring is
not going to stop some women but
that's another conversation
this will be the first time that i've
been back home since i moved to ethiopia
11 months ago
don't take off this ring
you too
right she's done that before and look at
baby avi he's so freaking cute and he
has no idea he's on 90 day fiance right
now please don't be too sad when i go
okay fast forward to when binium ari and
avi made it to the airport bam's
emotions intensified i love you so much
i love you so much
i feel so sad because
it's just one of the hardest things i
have to do just to leave vinnie
behind but
i hope he understands this is the right
thing and that
when i do come back
it will make us happier and stronger
benjamin revealed that saying bye to
them took him back to the exact moment
when he said goodbye to his ex-wife and
first son assuming that they would
return to ethiopia
at least
if you've never heard the sound of a
broken heart
that's it
[Music]
when it was time for ari and avi to
leave benjamin ran back to kiss them
both once again
so much and he admitted that he's scared
it's very hard okay let's just go go go
go go go
this feels like something out of a movie
ain't no sunshine when she's gone
it's not a war when she's away
any named
[Music]
i hope you don't come back would y'all
watch a show where 90 day stars go to
therapy
i would and that's no shade we all need
therapy at some point in our lives it
was just hard seeing binyam in pain like
that it was almost palpable
you know they say your emotional trauma
whether you like it or not will keep
presenting itself so it can be healed
that could be why he found himself in
such a similar situation again it might
be time for him to sit down and really
deal with those feelings i'm not saying
it'll fill the hole he has for his son
but hopefully
it will help
and i'm meeting up with her to apologize
for basically ghosting her so we can
both get some closure on our
relationship alright moving on to
someone else who had it rough this
episode but i'm not feeling bad for him
i'm talking corey after not seeing her
for seven months he met up with his
ex-girlfriend jenny who he was dating
while he and evelyn were on a break
but still married
i want you to know during their chat he
made sure to let her know that his time
with her was quote honestly real and he
had a lot of feelings for her i want you
to know that which
is a line that i think at this point
guys just need to retire
[Music]
overall here are my three takeaways from
their sit down
one
jenny didn't have any anger or hostility
toward corey for ghosting her which is
actually pretty impressive two
she described what they had together as
beautiful
and i would love to know what made it so
beautiful because she also revealed that
he lied to her and told her he was
single and it wasn't until after they
were together for two months that she
found out he was married if you can
still find beauty in it after that
something must have been good
she even said words will not give what
they had together justice
okay
my third takeaway last but certainly not
least in the middle of their
conversation miss jenny told corey to
wrap it up because she had a date
yeah i don't know if she was being
honest or trying to make him jealous
either way she had him flustered do you
still have feelings for jimmy
that's a big one man
oh that's a big question can i take a
sip i'll take a little sip
how's there any tequila back there yeah
i have feelings for jenny as a person i
really do care about the time we spend
together but
my heart and my love and
my future is with evelyn well that's
what you thought corey after leaving
jenny he built up enough courage to also
admit the full troops to evelyn after
telling her for months that what he had
with jenny was just a fling you know i
love you beautiful right
yes and he started with that line jenny
was more serious than
what i led on to believe
all serious like what do you mean if
you're moms like
yeah we we were actually
in a relationship
why just now you tell me about it
because you have denied it the whole
time i know that you'll be in south
america and being on white and blue ice
you think the women are gonna want you
and love you all the time
like what the [ __ ] do you think you are
like some kind of bracket damn
i didn't expect for her to start
roasting him can you be more gross
evelyn did admit that at the time she
told him it was okay for them to date
other people but what she claims to be
upset about now are all of his lies
he created more lies to cover all their
lives i cannot take this anymore so i
need a divorce after evelyn heard the
news she didn't hesitate to tell corey
to pack his bags
and leave i want him to suffer
i hope it's so cold outside there is a
million mosquitoes to buy him
i don't know what i'm gonna do like i
i've got a hammock i can set up to stay
the night and i just hope that she'll
come to her senses lucky for corey by
the time knight came evelyn had a change
of heart and allowed him to sleep on a
mattress in the house but sleep did not
calm her down like corey hoped how did
you even sleep and lie to my face if
anything
it made it worse you swear on your dead
died you swear and it's all lies there
is no more wedding there is no more
nothing and now i'm screwed because i
told my mom
and my whole family is gonna hate the
idea of a divorce because i have no idea
how much you suck she is like the insult
machine
they just keep coming
well she told cory to book a flight back
to america but next week it looks like
he is not going to give up that easily i
want you gone
are you gonna sign the divorce papers if
evelyn serves me with divorce papers
right now i'll rip them up in her face i
don't
want this to be nasty
i don't want to have police involved but
i will do that if you don't leave
oh
they are playing a messy game
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because we are covering
it all i will see you next time
[Music]